BOB KILLEN: Hello, everyone.
And welcome to What's
Next in Kubernetes.
I'm Bob Killen, a program
manager within Google's Open
Source Programs Office,
also a longtime contributor
to the Open Source
Kubernetes project.
And I'm here to
talk a little bit
about some of the overarching
future paths for Kubernetes.
But before I can dig
into what's next,
I need to talk a little
about where we've been,
what it's taken for
Kubernetes to become
the foundational platform
that powers so much today.
From a high level, you can sort
of break down Kubernetes phases
into three broad layers that
highlight a focus or theme
in the project's lifecycle.
The first and the
longest was four years,
from June 2014 to March 2018.
This is a period of
rapid growth, where
all the various
resource types are
being defined and solidified.
These are the basic
components that
are used by everything else.
Think of the core workloads,
such as deployments,
stateful sets, and
all the others.
These core workloads graduated
to GA in the 1.9 release
and was shortly
thereafter recognized
by the Cloud Native Computing
Foundation's Technical
Oversight Committee, approving
the project for graduation.
Kubernetes was the first
project to achieve the status.
It was recognized
for being stable,
used by a number of companies,
having a diverse contributor
base and solid
project governance.
This is the foundational stage.
And every future thing
is built on top of it.
The second phase, from March
2018 to September 2019,
is marked by the graduation of
custom resource definitions,
or CRDs--
a unified pattern to
extend Kubernetes.
It created an entire ecosystem
allowing people, projects,
and organizations
to create and manage
their own applications in
any other sort of Kubernetes
resource.
Instead of managing
these deployments,
you can now directly
manage things,
like a database
or a game server,
in a Kubernetes native way.
It was huge for the
cloud native landscape.
And if you look at the CNCF,
with its 100 or so projects,
you'll find that the majority
of them are using CRDs.
This last phase, from
late 2019 to August 2020,
isn't noted by a new feature,
but a shift in the mentality
of the project.
We built our core
workload types.
We've made the project
easy to extend.
And now with more users
than ever using the project,
we shifted to support
mobility and stability.
Policies and processes
were put in place
to help ensure every
feature being developed
was observable, scalable,
could be rolled back,
and a slew of other important
things for general operations.
And in doing so, we
were more comfortable
expanding our support window,
with new releases being
supported for a full year.
We built our core, we made it
easy to extend and integrate
with, and then
committed ourselves
to a stronger support policy.
So that takes us to now
and where we're going.
And I'll keep the theme for
this one sort of a secret
to the end.
But I want to give
you an idea of some
of the features and areas
of where we're focusing.
And for that, I picked
two big things to follow.
The first is multi-cluster.
So why multi-cluster?
Kubernetes has done a lot to
help people rethink and reshape
their architecture
and build more
resilient and scalable systems.
But for many use
cases, you can't just
build a larger cluster.
Say you want global availability
and to minimize the latency
to your customers.
That's something
you can't easily
do with a single cluster.
Or you might want to scale
and burst your workloads,
especially in something like a
hybrid environment where you've
outgrown your on-prem hardware
and want to burst to the cloud.
You may also be working with
privileged or sensitive data,
and want to maximize your
security by using clusters
as a security boundary.
Or lastly, you may just want
to make your application more
resilient by running multiple
clusters in HA and to segment
your failure domains.
The list goes on.
And it's often one
of the first places
organizations go to after
getting up and going
with a single cluster.
Now with that, I'm going to
go out a little on a limb.
But in a multi-cluster world,
clusters are the new pod.
As management of Kubernetes
clusters becomes easier,
it allows you to focus on
the important parts, namely
your application.
Clusters are becoming a tightly
coupled grouping of these app
components that you might
want to scale and secure
independently.
So just like a deployment
manages the pods and help scale
them up and down and
manages their life cycle,
you should be able to do
that with clusters too.
So why has this been so hard?
Well, to be frank,
multi-cluster configurations
in their current form are
incredibly complex with a lot
of moving parts.
If you have a
database in cluster A
that should be accessible to
some component in cluster B,
it requires a lot of
additional plumbing
of services between clusters--
often, additional load
balancers or a mix of them
with a service mesh.
It's not fun and
by no means easy.
Also, to be frank,
Kubernetes was honestly
not really designed
for multi-cluster
in mind initially.
But this has been
long recognized
by the upstream community.
And there have been several
initiatives targeting
and improving this use case.
The first is the introduction
of multi-cluster services,
a new CRD that standardizes
the way in which you
can share Kubernetes
services across clusters.
No more additional provisioning
of load balancers, no more
hodgepodge custom DNS rules
that require manual updating.
You define a cluster set or a
group of two or more clusters
and decide which
services in each cluster
you want to expose.
And a new controller will
just take care of the rest.
For your applications,
all you have to do
is them to a new cluster set
service DNS entry instead
of the regular cluster.local
one that we all
are sort of used to.
And with that, your traffic
will be routed appropriately.
Now, this is a
very simple model.
And it was specifically
designed to be that way
to address the complexity
of cross cluster networking
and service discovery
to make it easy to use
as a drop in replacement
for current services.
Now, there's a lot that
goes on under the hood.
But you as a user do not need
to manage those aspects of it.
So now that we have these
multi cluster services that
can help you manage your
cross cluster networking,
how about Ingress?
How do you manage
getting traffic
into your cluster
at a global level?
Well, there's something
for that too--
the Gateway API.
Think of it as
Ingress version 2.0.
It was designed with
all the lessons learned
from the original
Kubernetes Ingress
implementation with
many of the pain points,
such as excessive use of
annotations being addressed.
And for the purposes
of multi-cluster,
it can use the exports from
the multi-cluster services
API as a valid
back end, allowing
you to manage your
Ingresses at a global level.
Now, for GKE,
these two resources
have come together to offer
a very flexible and powerful
system.
Within GKE, there are two
fundamental different types
of clusters--
standard, where you
retain full control,
and autopilot, where much
of the management aspects
are abstracted away
and managed by Google.
Autopilot is a great
option for many workloads.
It comes with advantages like
better security and per pod
billing.
But there are some workloads
that don't necessarily
lend itself to it well, namely
large stateful applications
or things where you may need to
run in a pod in privilege mode.
But that's where
multi-cluster comes in.
What if we can interconnect
and deploy apps
where they fit
best without having
to worry about the plumbing?
You'd be able to take advantage
of the greater security and per
pod billing for most
resources in autopilot
and retain the greater
control over just the parts
of your stack that need it
in a standard cluster while,
honestly, managing them in
a dramatically easier way.
And that's part of the
future we're working towards.
So now that we've
covered multi-cluster,
let's take a look at
the next focus area.
And that's in the area of
AI/ML and batch computing.
Now, this is an
area that's actually
near and dear to my heart.
Before I started at Google,
I was heavily involved
in research computing
and exploring
Kubernetes for high
performance computing needs.
And while there
have been advances
in what I'll say broadly
as research computing
on top of Kubernetes,
there has generally
been a much slower
rate of adoption of it
versus, I'll say, more
traditional applications.
And that's because it's hard
for a number of reasons.
First and foremost, the
Kubernetes scheduler
is built for bin packing,
or trying to cram as much
on a single node
as possible, which
tends to go against most
really resource intensive jobs.
It also doesn't support the
concept of co-scheduling, where
you block scheduling
until there's
enough resources available
to run your entire job.
The other thing is most of
these research applications also
require a lot of tuning--
the application, the underlying
system or host OS, and also
things like the API server.
If you're spinning up hundreds
of thousands of tasks,
you need everything to be
working at peak performance
and to be able to handle
that sort of scale.
Now, there are a few
things coming in the pipes
to help improve this.
But I want to focus
on one thing that
has been an open request
for a very long time
and will help reduce the
complexity of work queues.
Works queues are a
fairly simple in concept.
They are a list of tasks or
data intended to be processed
by one or more workers.
They are by far the
most common work pattern
seen in AI/ML and batch.
You're providing a data
set and iterating over it
in parallel for
training or processing.
And Kubernetes has not really
supported this workflow
natively.
It's always required some
other external system,
such as Pub/Sub to keep track
of what's being processed.
This also means
that you must have
bake in more sort of
middleware logic into your job,
just to be able to process it.
It works.
Organizations have been
using this pattern since jobs
were a thing in Kubernetes.
But do you really
want to do that?
Or would you rather
rely on something
that could be done natively?
I'd pick the latter.
So in Kubernetes 1.21,
a new alpha feature
was added to jobs--
a completion mode, where if
you specify it as indexed,
each pod is given a
numbered identifier
with the index starting at 0.
This index will be
used in the generation
of the pods hostnames, giving
it something predictable akin
to stateful sets.
That index is also passed
into the pod as an environment
variable.
And what this does is it
gives you the ability--
a built in native way to
statically assign data
to the processes of each pod.
It will require a little bit
of planning ahead of time.
But you won't have to
run an external system.
You won't have to bake something
into your code for the job just
to pull items from the queue.
It reduces the overall
complexity of work queues
significantly.
And this seems
like a small thing.
But it solves a problem
for a lot of people.
In addition to this, there
are also several other things
in the works that
will enable or AI/ML
and batch types of workloads--
things like the
scheduler framework,
where instead of trying to
make the committee scheduler be
everything to everyone,
many more hooks and methods
of integrating with
it have been created.
It's now significantly easier
to extend and customize
how scheduling is done
by assigning workloads
to different
scheduling profiles.
Jobs can also now be suspended.
And what this means is that
if you say a higher priority
job is to be scheduled,
the lower priority job
can be suspended until
the higher priority
job is completed.
It doesn't have
to be rescheduled.
Work can pick back up when the
higher priority job is done--
something we've seen in
a lot of classic batch
systems for years.
Lastly, there's been some
changes to the Kubernetes API
server so it can be tuned
to support the exceedingly
high throughput of requests that
often come in with batch job
oriented systems.
And all these
things combined will
make running AI/ML and batch
workloads significantly easier
on top of Kubernetes.
And at this point with
that sort of short preview
of the improvements to
things like multi-cluster
and AI/ML and
batch, you may have
started to pick up on a theme.
What is Kubernetes?
Kubernetes is foundational.
We spent four years
building a strong base.
All the core workloads
and design patterns
that you depend on
today started here.
It is extensible.
A year and a half were spent
making it easy for people
to adopt, build, and
extend on that foundation,
creating an ecosystem that is
just absolutely massive today.
Kubernetes is mature.
We put a lot of
effort into making
sure you can depend on every
feature and every release.
And we demonstrated this by
extending our support window.
So what is Kubernetes now?
Is it easy?
Well, we're not there yet.
We're making it
easier for you to use.
We're reducing much
of the complexity that
has forced people
into workarounds
and building our large,
more complex systems.
A lot of these features
and improvements
may seem minor at first look.
But all of them
are there to help
improve the various
workflows that people
have built around and
on top of Kubernetes.
And as we make Kubernetes
easier for people to use,
it will also enable a
whole new set of use cases
that we haven't imagined yet.
So Kubernetes isn't easy yet.
But we'll get there.
And with that, if you are
interested in learning more
about some of the stuff
I talked about today,
here are some
additional resources
that you might find useful.
In particular, I want to
highlight the Learn Kubernetes
with Google Video series.
You'll find videos
going over how
you can get going with
multi-cluster index jobs
and quite a bit more.
Thank you.
And I look forward to building
the future of Kubernetes
with you.